THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT
ANGLE.
LATE MONDAY NIGHT FRESHMAN
CONGRESSMAN -- CONGRESSWOMAN
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ FOUND
HERSELF IN SOME HOT WATER WHEN
SHE SAID THIS ABOUT THE MIGRANT
DETENTION CENTERS AT OUR BORDER
BORDERS.
>> THE UNITED STATES IS RUNNING
CONCENTRATION CAMPS ON OUR
SOUTHERN BORDERS.
AND THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT THEY
ARE.
I WANT TO TALK TO THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE CONCERNED ENOUGH WITH
HUMANITY TO SAY THAT WE SHOULD
NOT -- AND NEVER AGAIN MEAN
SOMETHING.
>> Laura: THE COMMENTS WERE
NOT JUST IN ARTFUL, THEY WERE AN
INSULT TO THE MILLIONS WHO DIED
IN THE CONCENTRATION CAMPS, MANY
WHO SURVIVED, AND THE MILLIONS
ACROSS THE GLOBE WHO ARE TRYING
TO ENSURE THAT AN ATROCITY LIKE
THE HOLOCAUST NEVER HAPPENS
AGAIN.
BUT, INSTEAD OF SAYING SHE
MISSPOKE OR APOLOGIZING, SHE
KEEPS DIGGING.
>> I JUST DEFINITION OF CON
>> I JUST DEFINITION OF COE
>> I JUST DEFINITION OF COT
>> I JUST DEFINITION OF COA
>> I JUST DEFINITION OF COI
>> I JUST DEFINITION OF CON
CAMPS ARE TARGETING A COMMUNITY
AND PUTTING THEM IN DETENTION
CAMPS WITHOUT A TRIAL, AND THAT
IS WHAT THE GOVERNMENT IS DOING.
>> Laura: AND TODAY,
OCASIO-CORTEZ REMAINS
UNREPENTANT, TWEETING IN PART "I
WILL NEVER APOLOGIZE FOR CALLING
THESE CAMPS WHAT THEY ARE."
IN THE WAKE OF ALL OF THOSE
COMMENTS, THE MOST PROMINENT AND
APOLITICAL JEWISH ORGANIZATIONS
IN THE WORLD SPOKE OUT.
THE WORLD CENTER FOR HOLOCAUST
RESEARCH AND DOCUMENTATION
OFFERED THIS CLARIFICATION FOR
OCASIO-CORTEZ VIA TWITTER.
AOC CONCENTRATION CAMPS ASSURED
A LABOR SUPPLY.
THE REALITY IN THE CAMP SURE THE
ULTIMATE GOAL OF EXTERMINATION
THROUGH LABOR.
BUT ON THE OTHER SIDE, MANY OF
OCASIO-CORTEZ'S DEMOCRATIC PEERS
AND THE MEDIA -- THEY SPRINTED
TO HER DEFENSE.
>> I AGREE WITH THE SENTIMENT
BEHIND WHAT SHE SAID, WHICH IS
THAT WE CAN TO TAKE THIS AS
NORMAL.
>> THE TRUTH IS, WE ARE CREATING
CONCENTRATION CAMPS ON THE
BORDER.
>> IN 1933, THERE WERE
CONCENTRATION CAMPS, IN 1941,
THERE WERE DEATH CAMPS, AND THAT
IS WHERE WE ARE GOING IF OUR
CONSCIENCES --
>> Laura: THIS SEQUENCE OF
EVENTS MIGHT BE THE MOST JARRIN
JARRING.
WHEN LIZ CHENEY SUGGESTED AOC
SHOULD LEARN HISTORY, STEPPED IN
FOR WHAT IS THE LEFT CALL IT?
MANS PLATING.
IF YOU SPEND A FEW MINUTES
LEARNING SOME ACTUAL HISTORY,
YOU WILL FIND OUT THAT
CONCENTRATION CAMPS ARE
DIFFERENT FROM DEATH CAMPS, AND
HAVE A HISTORY THAT BOTH
PREDATES AND EXTENDS FAR PAST
THE.
TO THAT, THE ACTUAL TWITTER
ACCOUNT FOR THE MUSEUM DEDICATED
TO AUSCHWITZ ON THE MEMORIAL HIT
BACK AT HAYES AND RECOMMENDED
THAT HE "CONSIDER THE FOLLOWING
AT AUSCHWITZ MUSEUM WHERE EVERY
DAY WE COMMEND HIM TO
COMMEMORATE AND EDUCATE ABOUT
THE TRAGIC HUMAN HISTORY OF
AUSCHWITZ.
"ONE MIGHT THINK BEING CALLED
OUT BY ONE OF THE MORE SOLEMN
HISTORICAL MUSEUMS ON THE PLANET
WOULD HAVE STOPPED HIM IN HIS
TRACKS, YET HOURS OF LATER ON HE
SHOWED, HAYES INVITED A GUEST ON
TO PLAY DEFENSE FOR HIM.
>> I WOULD SAY FOR 40 YEARS
BEFORE AUSCHWITZ, WE HAD
CONCENTRATION CAMPS, THINGS THAT
RECALLED CONCENTRATION CAMPS.
WHAT WE ARE DOING NOW FITS VERY
CLEANLY INSIDE THAT TRADITION.
>> Laura: VERY CLEARLY INSIDE
THAT TRADITION.
[LAUGHS]
YOU ASK YOURSELF THIS: IS THE
UNITED STATES INDISCRIMINATELY
ROUNDING UP PEOPLE BASED ON
COLOR OF THEIR SKIN OR ETHNICITY
AND SENDING THEM TO THESE CAMPS?
NO.
ARE WE TEMPORARILY HOLDING
PEOPLE WHO ARE COMING OVER THE
BORDER ILLEGALLY?
ORDER OF THEIR OWN VOLITION?
YES, WE ARE.
SADLY, THOUGH, THIS IS JUST PART
OF A LARGER EFFORT, AND WE HAVE
DOCUMENTED THIS ON THE SHOW PEER
THE PRESIDENTS ENEMIES ARE
TRYING TO SITUATE NOT JUST HIS
POLICIES BUT HIS ENTIRE
PRESIDENCY SOMEWHERE NEAR BERLIN
FOR THE 1940s.
HERE IS AN ILLUMINATING
CONVERSATION BETWEEN CNN'S CHRIS
CUOMO AND DON LEMMON ABOUT THE
NETWORK'S DECISION TO CUT AWAY
FROM TRUMP'S 2020 REELECTION
LAUNCH LAST NIGHT.
>> THINK ABOUT THE DESPICABLE
PEOPLE WE HAVE HAD IN HISTORY.
I'M GOING TO USE AN EXTREME
EXAMPLE.
THINK ABOUT HITLER.
IF YOU COULD LOOK BACK IN
HISTORY, WOULD YOU SAY WELL, I'M
SO GLAD THAT THAT PERSON WAS
ALLOWED A PLATFORM SO THAT THEY
COULD SPREAD THEIR HATE AND
PROPAGANDA AND LIES.
OR WOULD YOU SAY THERE PROBABLY
WASN'T THE RIGHT THING TO DO TOS
WASN'T THE RIGHT THING TO DO TOR
WASN'T THE RIGHT THING TO DO TOA
WASN'T THE RIGHT THING TO DO TOD
WASN'T THE RIGHT THING TO DO TOT
WASN'T THE RIGHT THING TO DO TOA
WASN'T THE RIGHT THING TO DO TO?
BECAUSE YOU KNEW, IN THE MOMENT,
THAT THAT WAS A BAD PERSON PAIR
NOT ONLY WERE THEY HURTING
PEOPLE, THEY WERE KILLING
PEOPLE.
IT STARTS WITH LITTLE LIES THAT
BECOME BIGGER LIES.
>> Laura: SHOCKER, HIS RATINGS
ARE NOT STRATOSPHERIC.
IT IS SO TRANSPARENT WHAT THEY
ARE DOING.
IT IS ACTUALLY SAD, INFURIATING,
BUT ALSO SAD.
THE PEOPLE CAN'T BE THIS DUMB.
IT IS REALLY PERNICIOUS, WHICH
IS REALLY DEPRESSING.
WITHIN 24 HOURS, JUST AS THE
PRESIDENT ANNOUNCED THE 2020
RELAUNCH, DEMOCRATS AND THEIR
MEDIA ALLIES ARE HURLING ATTACKS
AGAINST THE ADMINISTRATION THAT
CONJURE UP SOME OF THE MOST
HORRIBLE ATROCITIES EVER
COMMITTED AGAINST HUMANKIND.
SO FOR THE LEFT, WHEN YOU DON'T
HAVE AN ARGUMENT, WHAT DO YOU
DO?
SLANDER WILL ALWAYS DO.
BUT INVOKING THE HOLOCAUST?
TO SCORE POLITICAL POINTS?
THERE ARE NO WORDS, EVEN FOR
CNN.
THERE'S JUST NO WORDS.
YOU HAVE TO BE BETTER THAN MATT.
THOSE PROPAGATING THESE
DISGUSTING SMEARS SHOULD NOT
ONLY BE ASHAMED FOR THE PAIN IN
THE REAL DIVISION THEY ARE
CAUSING, BUT THEY SHOULD
APOLOGIZE IN THE NAME OF COMMON